the jurogan experience so you made a
movie
about the story that you told on the
podcast about a guy
who pretended that he was from yale and
you and then you found out
later in your relationship that he was
not and he was completely full of [ __ ]
yeah i told that story on your podcast a
couple years ago and i was trying to
think
if that was the first time i'd ever been
on your podcast
in this iteration like as the huge joe
rogan experience podcast
i couldn't remember if i'd been on it
before prior to that
i think you had i think so too but i
think i was like that would be the
perfect
book end to this story because the first
time i told it
in its totality was here and then
here i am and i've made this movie it's
such a crazy story
yeah the fact that the guy that that
really was what he was doing he was just
completely lying
yeah about his background and who he was
and
but it worked for a little while well
you know
so i remember when i told the story and
of course the feedback's all like you're
a
dumb [ __ ] what's wrong why is there a
woman talking about anything
and so i was just like okay i gotta be
careful in the way that i parse out this
narrative
and my answer is you know there's red
flags that we're taught to think about
you know you're walking down the street
in new york city and someone gives you a
look you got red flags right you're at a
um you're doing a business deal there's
red flags
in a relationship you know because of
music and tv we're all thought to think
about cheating right
and lying in that way i meet you
randomly and in the first five minutes
i'm like where'd you go to school what
do you do
i wouldn't i don't want to be the kind
of person that has a radar up
because these weren't lies like i'm the
king of spain i have a fleet of yachts
at my disposal
it was like i went to yale just like my
cousin did and i do hedge funds like
okay normal normal and that's how these
kind of people get by and so these
weren't
you met this guy on a plane right an
airplane an airplane as if there's a
difference like not like just a grassy
plane
specifically an airplane
heading into a gig he was sitting next
to you i was coming over thanksgiving
oh i was just on my family some of them
are on the east coast and i
my big thing as a com like i always my
whole career i spend the money on the
travel like that's a great investment
like buy that first class ticket when
you travel so much i'm like that's where
the money goes
and you're usually sitting next to
someone who looks like your dad in first
class
it's i seldom that i and this was i was
probably 29 at the time
28 29 seldom you're sitting next to
someone around your age
you know and here's a guy and so we just
start talking because we're this around
the same age
um and that then we just got along
super he was funny he was dorky but
smart like just a cool guy and i
he had a girlfriend and i had a boy
picking me up at the airport and i think
we exchanged like twitter handles
like this wasn't like uh salacious like
give me your details
and i was like if you own your
girlfriend ever want to come to a show
you know you're a comic you get it like
a comedy store
i get paid the same way either way so
come on down to the store but we became
friends
and what made it easy was when you're a
comic you keep such odd hours like how
many times have you eaten dinner at like
one in the morning
and you're like a dude out for protein i
have to eat late at night i usually
don't eat at night
all right cool i intermittent fast too
that's what i do on it
uh but i can't do my voice on it
as i think it's just my generic beefy
guy that could be you
that could be me bro what you don't
understand is that it's just a structure
within a democracy which is a man-made
construct
whoa that good it's not bad it's not bad
it's not bad
i'd have to i'd have to it's pro talk
that's like bro
bro politics it's probably pro
intelligent talk yeah
so what did this guy actually do what
was his actual job
he worked at a hedge fund um
and i mean who checks that
would a person who works at a hedge fund
know the difference between
a club headliner and a theater headliner
like there's
level like why okay that sounds really
boring
and whatever i get that that's with
numbers and
and money but he went to a college you
went to a college
just not that one just lied about yale
right yeah that's what i found
out way later work at a hedge fund yeah
but i think it was like super low level
like he made it like oh i'm starting my
own business and
you know you're 29 years old you're
sitting in a first class seat
and you're dressed like a dork and
you're talking about why wouldn't i
believe you i have plenty of friends who
are successful at things
yeah other than stand up and most you
know so my point was that if he just was
himself
yes and he just said i'm working at a
hedge fund and was the same guy just as
funny
you completely keyed in on it the whole
takeaway from the movie is
all the things that he didn't lie about
were the things that i actually valued
the most
he was you cannot fake intelligence you
cannot fake sense of humor
right you cannot fake wit right and he
had those
he had those things he was unattractive
which is probably a big source of his
insecurity and whatever else society put
on him but
that was the sad part was i wasn't that
impressed by going to a good school and
having a job i've never heard of
right hey you just said like i went to
this regular school and i
do this i still would have said come to
the comedy store i still would have had
drinks
so that's a it's not a shame because i i
really am into my husband
and the way that that worked out but
that's the weird
the sad part is that we put rather than
just be good at something
someone just like lied and built a whole
world around it have you
kept in time in touch with that guy oh
yeah we hang out all the time
no oh my god no but it's so gross
no i mean he's never reached out and
said hey i heard that story
no nothing i uh no
how long did you date him for only three
months
we are friends for a full year which is
why
it kind it you don't question your
friends as much
right and here's someone that always
showed up the dudes in my group like all
the comics that you know that i'm
friends like they've all met him like we
go out drinking
and my schedule is so weird so i'd be
like i need to get dinner at like 11
he'd be down for it i was like great
this is got a malleable schedule
and we were friends for that year i have
best friends in la and i've been to
their apartment
twice right in 15 years so you're not um
checking on things because i just take
it it's normal at face value where you
live and stuff like that and to be
honest
the closer he became his friends the
more he like he was like look i really
like you
and we would always you know you're in
your 20s so you're going out drinking
i never wanted to go to his house like
he would meet me at my
condo and we would go or my friends
would come over because i was like
there's no reason
if you know that if i know you like me
and i don't like you
there's no reason for me to go to your
house like you're
very wise on neutral territory it's not
i'm not afraid of my physical safety but
in terms of messaging i think that's a
little like i don't like you but i'll
get drunk and
hang out in your room we're not doing
that i got a house
smart there's a bar right right and i
was very honest the whole time i'm like
i'm just not there yet and i do go on
dates
i like how you said yet though it's like
oh you're saying there's a chance
uh that was i think i was just doing the
number until you're saying there's a
chance
which is how guys think yeah but i was
very honest
very honest in in being like look there
was a chance because you wound up
getting together with them yeah but i
didn't see it that way that's like ah
but you get it i mean that's you're
talking about an eventuality that no one
could foresee
because i was dating other people right
right consistency was key
uh well actually dudes will hang out in
that friend zone i hear that and i would
always say
i'm not into you in fact i'm going on a
date tonight but by the way if you
if you can't handle that and you don't
want to be my friend that's okay
i would give him these outs right and
the truth is
i wasn't into him we were very close as
friends
and then one day he told me his mom had
cancer oh i remember this book right
so as a human and as a woman you know
like there's a vulnerability that he
cried
probably thinking about he's probably
crying about what a good liar he is but
like
his mom didn't really have cancer no
yeah that's what's [ __ ] up i remember
this
and i forgot that part of it i met her
we had just so like you know my heart
opened up and you can as a woman you can
become
this is my big thing you can become
attracted to a man
who you are physically not attracted to
because of personality
men it doesn't work joe you've never
been like that girl is a warthog
but it turns out she's really funny so i
do want to put my mouth on hers
like you've never in your life been like
but she got a great personality
but girls do it's just we're cerebral
you know and men are very visual and so
it was
all the kindness how smart how funny all
this stuff
mom got cancer i'm like oh my god i need
to be there for this person who's been
nothing but
kind to me as a human and my heart
opened up
whatever and i met her it was around the
holidays and so we uh
yeah because we met in november and this
was i remember i was going like
christmas craft shopping and uh we met
at like a craft store
and she was there and i'd never you know
she has cancer and he said she's very
sick so i didn't want to be indelicate
i didn't want to be like how'd you
cancer susan
you know so i remember asking her like
how are you feeling and of course this
woman's like feeling fine
why have you heard otherwise oh god and
we only talked for like a half hour you
know and i remember at the time thinking
like oh this is a guy that i really like
and i
if she's gonna die i want her to know
that her her son is with someone who's
kind
i remember thinking that wow because
that's so heavy they're so heavy and i
didn't find out that she didn't have the
cancer until after i realized all the
lies and i'd
broken her up i ran into some mutual
friends and i was like i just you know
he's a [ __ ] loser
literally insane that's an insane person
he's an insane person but also the story
is so insane
and you still have to tread lightly as a
woman because people find fault no
matter what you do
like i remember someone saying like well
you're a gold digger and i was like
how's that now
like i've made a bunch of my own money
since i was like 25
no but it opened my eyes up to the
perception just of when you tell a story
that's so honest
the feedback that you get and you're
like okay let me control this narrative
so that's why in the movie
she's not some struggling i put her as
like a mostly successful to show like
this doesn't like
she needed anything right a lot of
articles are like she was so strong it's
like no no
she just didn't wake up and die i wonder
what other
lies that guy because that's not a guy
who's done that for the first time like
if someone's lying about their mom
having cancer
oh my god that's such a crazy lie such
bad karma
what what a what bad energy to go
through life like that it's like
the momentum of all those lies must be
like inescapable like how does one stop
and become an honest person when you're
lying about that many things
and intimate things like your mother the
person who gave
life to you you're lying and saying that
she has cancer so that a girl will like
you more
yeah it's really insane super beta and
it's well it's it's a pattern
that's a strange pattern because like
what makes people lie
you know uh feeling insufficient
you know feeling that you and this is
for better for worse
we hold men to a certain standard in our
society i'm not excusing this behavior
i'm just saying
you know men who don't want to be
sensitive or don't want to cry or are
afraid to show vulnerability because we
have this like macho archetype
most women don't actually expect that
and they want you to be yourself and
open up and
but we do just as we put things on women
we do put things on men and we don't
have conversations about that
the difference is men don't realize like
all you gotta do is go out i talk about
this on stage and like
just be good at something and there will
be a girl who will like
ride or die with you in your toyota
passenger seat like that's my baby he's
the best mustache grower
like b all these comics that we're
talking about they all [ __ ]
funny guys [ __ ] so you should be funny
you don't have to be attractive you
could just be kind
you could just be good at like magic the
gathering
there's a girl that's cool with it but
some people just think if i
posture and i lie i'll get the kind of
girl i deserve
don't you think it's also that kind of
like financial world
like the financial world is very much
about
filled with sociopaths there's a lot of
that sure but it's all about like what
kind of car do you drive what kind of
watch do you have where is your
where's your house at you know what how
much money are you making how much did
you make last year what's your
what's your end goal so those archetypes
like that patina of a person
right like you have to be the what's his
name an american psycho yeah
bateman patrick bateman having to be
that and the whole movie's about that
expectation
uh the business card things like that i
mean i didn't include
he told me he was in skull and bones oh
christ
and i remember thinking like i don't
know that's a pretty that's a pretty big
secret
people and he invited me he's like i'm
going to london for
like a reunion like an event do you want
to come and i was like
sort of but i do need my own room like
i'm not going to share a room with you
and then of course he ended up not going
of course
but there are things where they're so
out of my room like i am not in skull
and bones and it seems so foreign so
you fit the bill i guess you could be i
think wouldn't you think he'd be more
successful
if he wasn't skull and bones isn't that
one of those things where you're
connected to all those
well how do you gauge how successful
someone is by their car because he drove
a really nice
car did he and i never saw his house and
he dressed well
and he spoke like okay so you thought he
was very successful i just he presented
as
a kid that i went to school with but he
obviously was kind of doing well
if he did work for a hedge fund right
anyone can
they will let almost anyone sign a lease
to a nice car
what kind of car was it it was like an
audi i couldn't tell you what kind
but a nice car it's in it yeah so
doing pretty good i guess so but i also
like
wasn't so impressed like i had my own
condo you don't give a [ __ ] anyway if a
guy had a porsche and he lived in a my
husband drives a mazda
and i drive a honda civic hybrid that i
tell people i won on last comic standing
do you still have that that's how i
reflect you still have that [ __ ] i
love
it wow catch new episodes of the joe
rogan experience
for free only on spotify watch back
catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background while using other apps
and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience